president Trump is in Las Vegas this
morning in the middle of a two-day
political trip CBS news political
correspondent ed O'Keefe went there to
ask for voters two Democrats and two
Republicans about the midterm elections
and the claim the Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh assaulted a woman in
high school and us from Las Vegas ed
good morning good morning guys well
everyone back in Washington's trying to
sort out what to do about the
accusations against Frank Cavanaugh we
found people here are closely watching
the back-and-forth and expect to hear
soon from both sides in public I think
it should be investigated I had mixed
feelings about that because I felt okay
none of us are the person that we were
in high school but on the other hand it
was very important to my husband and
myself when we raise our child to our
son to tell him that no means no and you
respect women you don't appease women so
I think that the issue with Brett
Kavanaugh is that as a judge and as a
justice he's going to be ruling on
sexual assault cases so we need to know
about this because maybe he secretly
doesn't think that sexual assault is a
problem and that might in fact his
rulings I do believe she should have
mrs. Furth doctor for every opportunity
to explain her side I absolutely believe
that mr. Cavanaugh should have his side
but the the continual tugging and
pulling and everything is just political
gamesmanship I think she definitely
needs to be heard out and I think it's
something that that everybody needs to
hear both sides of the story and and
then obviously the you know it's up to
the Senate to decide who they believe in
and what they believe do you want the
FBI involved in this or should they just
come and share their views and let the
Senators decide my view is that yes the
FBI should be involved want they're more
competent and investigations they have
more things at their hands that they can
reach to have more tools available to
them to do it that's not necessarily
something women want to talk about it's
not easy to talk about and if you think
back and I you're probably too young to
remember but I was around when the Anita
Hill issue came up and she was not
treated
well or nicely or any of that he has
been investigated by the FBI previously
and I don't know that bringing them in
now you know for an FBI investigation
makes a lot of sense I think you can't
ignore the the momentum of the mutant
movement right now and and that that
might have played a factor and sort of
given her support right right exact
thing I think we see that with with a
lot of these other cases where you know
women may have felt like they were alone
or not empowered or may have been shot
down or or dismissed before this this
wave in momentum started to build so I
think that definitely plays a factor you
know it's sometimes hard to gauge
whether or not the political battles
there in the Beltway really resonate in
the rest of the country and I think this
one proves that it definitely does which
probably means Republicans are gonna
have to let all those facts come out
before actually scheduling a vote you
seem to listen to them talk sometimes
it's more informative to hear from
average people than even politicians but
and add you also spoke with them about
gun violence what did the group tell you
about that that's right because remember
the the 1 October anniversary as they
call it here is coming up soon and they
agreed that while there hasn't been a
lot of change nationally when it comes
to gun control policy they agree that
here in Las Vegas at least they've seen
stepped-up security which is providing
more protection to tourists what they
hope to see at some point is solutions
to avoid the mass shooting that killed
more than 50 people here almost a year
ago yes that was the worst mass shooting
in US history at okay thank you
well this Sunday John Dickerson talks
with Republican congressman trey Gowdy
and Democratic congresswoman Anna issue
on Face the Nation here on CBS